[Music]
[Music]
despite all the praise i've given to
breath of the wild there's one aspect to
the game which
never said well with me no it wasn't the
rain or the weapon durability system or
anything like that
in the grander scheme of things to me
personally these are about minor
nitpicks that didn't impede my enjoyment
of the overall experience
even the way the story was portrayed was
never really a big issue for me
i thought it fit well with the gameplay
making it more natural for link to just
mess around before making his way to
hyrule castle no
the real gripe i had was with calamity
ganon
i am aware that for breath of the wild
anuma and his team wanted ganon to feel
more like a force of nature
rather than an actual individual and
while i can at least
understand that decision at the same
time something felt
off about it for a being that has caused
this much destruction and suffering to
hyrule
making him so faceless and abstract
kinda takes away from the feeling of
menace felt in previous installments
zelda might not be the pinnacle of
complex storytelling and intricate
character development but we have seen
villains throughout the series who are
cunning intelligent
and downright crazy and terrifying
calamity ganon seems to lack these
elements
he's just a thing floating around he
doesn't speak and it's hard to know
exactly what he even is
besides malice turned into a physical or
spectral form
in some cases having a faceless evil
entity that we rarely see
or cannot even see its true appearance
of can be very effective
the best example i can think of would be
sauron from lord of the rings
a disembodied eye atop a massive tower
which despite its weakened state is
still able to exert a menacing dominance
over middle earth in a lot of ways
sauron and calamity ganon have a lot in
common the dark lord
sauron forged in secret a master ring
to control all others and into this ring
he poured his cruelty his malice and his
will
to dominate all life both have eyes
everywhere to perceive the world from
different vantage points
both were defeated in a battle a long
time ago and are weakened to a point
where they themselves cannot physically
manifest but rather use corruption and
manipulation to have others do their
evil bidding they infest and destroy
nature and the balance of the world
around them
but the big difference here is that
sauron is always active building armies
and using his minions to corrupt key
figures and
simply staring at him or even talking
with him can be extremely dangerous and
well his presence is just downright
terrifying
calamity ganon doesn't really impose the
same type of fear
in my opinion it's one of the reasons
why the ending to the game felt so
unfulfilling in a lot of ways
linc and zelda defeat calamity ganon and
that's it
nothing has learned no curses are cast
motivations made clear
it just ends it is perhaps the most
open-ended zelda ending
ever created and of course at the time
we didn't know that a direct sequel
which
seems to pick up right after was going
to be made which explains why it was
such an underwhelming finale
perhaps another parallel to lord of the
rings which also just ends and then
picks up in the sequel
with breath of the wild 2 now underway
things have become
a lot more clear about calamity gannon
despite barely knowing anything about
the actual story or gameplay we have at
least learned
why calamity ganon felt like such a
nothing character
it's because he was nothing just a
manifestation of hatred being controlled
from deep underground by the true source
of evil
ganondorf it's actually very reminiscent
of phantom ganon it also explains why
despite calamity ganon being such a
faceless and seemingly brainless
character
you still seem to have an actual
intelligence behind it which
is reflected by his actions and what if
calamity ganon or rather
ganondorf's plan span much further back
and even seemingly unrelated events
might be attributed to his manipulation
and strategy
this puppet master puppet dynamic
fascinates me and it's a topic that i've
been wanting to cover for a while now
so strap in as we take a look at the
potentially much bigger picture
regarding ganondorf his malice and his
plans for hyrule
the first and most obvious indication of
calamity ganon possessing a clear
intelligence is of course the corruption
of the sheikh attack itself
right before the battle of ten thousand
years ago he arose just like he did
recently
what he didn't account for however was
that the ancient shika had built a
massive army of automata to stop him in
his tracks
and as his tradition after being
weakened by this mechanized army he was
struck by the sword of evil's bane and
sealed away by princess zelda of that
era who possessed the sealing power from
goddess hylia
however as we all know now this was just
malice not the actual individual
ganondorf himself
that got sealed it is made clear
throughout the story of the game and now
by the trailer for breath wall 2
that ganondorf spends around 10 000
years to gather up enough malice to
launch
another attack or calamity if you will
upon hyrule
during these 10 000 years ganondorf had
enough time to think of a new strategy
to deal with this newfound technology
he is a very patient man a strategy he
was finally able to put into practice
100 years ago by using his malice not to
just
manifest himself but also take control
of said technology
this is a clear indication that the
brain behind calamity gannon learned
from his defeat 10 000 years ago and has
been scheming all this time
but i feel like in terms of his plans
this may be only the tip of the iceberg
and there are several hints to this some
of which have been covered by other
theorists as well
first and foremost the prophecy nintendo
black crisis already made a great video
about how the prophecy
may have been misunderstood a prophecy
that miss reg could have been a few
years after zelda was born
a still unnamed person foretold the
return of ganon
there are some suggestions that this
might have been zelda's mother the queen
of hyrule but as of right now this has
yet to be confirmed and this fortune
teller as
he or she is referred to remains totally
anonymous
here's where one thing doesn't make
sense though before the calamity was
predicted by this unknown person the
shika technology was buried and
forgotten
had this foresight never come to light
ganon would have just appeared one day
and nobody would have seen it coming
but if ganondorf's plan was to take over
the guardians and divine beast by using
his malice all along
this plan would have only worked if the
ancient chica's technology was uncovered
by the time of his return
the message the fortune teller received
was literally that the way to oppose
gallon was buried beneath the ground
which of course led to the large-scale
excavations under the command of the
royal family as far as theories go
the one that appeals to me the most is
that what if this prophecy wasn't some
divine message
but rather a manipulation by ganondorf a
message from the king of evil
himself either through some telepathic
message or as some suggest a yiga spy or
other type of
ganon loyalist posing as the fortune
teller i mean think about it the only
way for ganondorf to be able to take
control of the most powerful and
dangerous army in zelda history and
execute his plan
required this army to be unearthed he
needed this army to be found before his
rise
and by announcing his return in advance
he knew that the highlands would go out
of their way to find these ancient
relics he may have seen the sheer power
and potential of this army during the
battle of 10 000 years ago and decided
that this was the force he sought for to
eradicate the kingdom of hyrule and his
patience paid off since
well when it comes to destroying the
kingdom he came as close as you could
possibly get
where ganon failed however was in
dealing with the hero and the princess
a failure that ultimately led to his
calamity being halted once again 100
years later but this isn't to say that
he didn't try
and there are clear signs of this first
off the death of the queen of hyrule is
already pretty suspicious
her sudden and unexpected passing is a
huge red flag if you ask me
and i'm a firm believer that this wasn't
some tragic accident but rather a
conscious attempt by ganondorf to mess
with zelda's ability to awaken her
sealing power
in my video about seeing zelda
potentially becoming queen in breath of
the wild 2 i mentioned that zelda's
mother might not have possessed the
sealing power herself but rather
zelda's grandmother and her mother might
have married into the royal family and
isn't part of the original bloodline
some comments pointed out that zelda's
wording during her prayer at the spring
of wisdom
does hint that her mother did possess a
certain power too though it is not made
clear if this is indeed the sacred
ceiling power or just some other type of
ability the wording is still
vague and not very clear exactly what
zelda means and open to interpretation
in true nintendo fashion of course
however for this
theory it doesn't really matter whether
or not the queen herself possessed this
ceiling power regardless
whatever the case may be by killing off
the queen ganondorf threw a wrench in
the works and prevented zelda from
unlocking her sacred gift before the day
of the great calamity either ganondorf
killed zelda's mother because she had
mastered the ceiling power herself and
would have been able to seal him when he
rose up or wanted to deprive zelda of a
mentor who could teach her to awaken and
control set power
either way ganondorf succeeded and by
the time zelda's ability did awaken
hyrule was already devastated the death
of the queen took place when zelda was
only around 6 years old but ganondorf's
attempts at messing with the hylians
plans don't seem to stop there
this is where we get into his main focus
besides getting ready to take over
hyrule castle
namely disposing of link and zelda
ganondorf has been around since the
distant past he knows full well what the
rules are and that the keys to his
defeat lie within the presence of the
hero wielding the sword that seals the
darkness
the master sword and the one who
possesses the blood of the goddess hylia
aka princess zelda if he wanted his plan
to eradicate hyrule once and for all to
succeed he had to get rid of them
or else similar to 10 000 years ago his
attempt may fail
yet again in the months leading up to
his appearance from deep below hyrule
castle some very significant events
started taking place
for one monsters around hyrule who
previously didn't even pose a problem
anymore for the kingdom
started to grow more restless and their
numbers started to increase
and they even went as far as to attack
travelers and settlements more
frequently and seemingly more
coordinated these attacks could of
course just have been random and
monsters doing what monsters do
but at the same time this could have
also been ganon's way of trying to catch
link and zelda in the crossfire of these
attacks in hopes that one or both would
not survive to tell the tale
zelda even mentions that she believes
the intensity and frequency of these
attacks to be an omen of ganon's looming
return
little did she know her and link may
have been the main target
additionally the yiga clan also started
to become more active and even made an
attempt to kill princess zelda while she
was visiting gerudo desert and this to
me is one of the biggest indicators of
ganondorf seemingly wanting to get rid
of zelda and link before he made his
grand return
this assassination attempt was likely
him trying to get rid of princess zelda
as an extra insurance that she will not
be there to awaken her powers and seal
his malice the day he makes his move
but what about link as far as we know he
seems to be doing just fine throughout
the moments leading up to the great
calamity right
aside from him being a total badass and
slaying hordes of monsters which
attacked the kingdom he never seems to
be a direct target
with the exception of one particular
cutscene
this scene where daruk is practicing to
get divine beast varadania under his
control while being accompanied by link
has always struck me as a bit
odd after taking the beast for a spin
the two start conversing about
ganon's return the rook's motivations
link's newly appointed tasks to protect
the princess
etc when all of a sudden the ground
starts to tremble and a huge boulder is
sent hurtling down towards the two
and had it not been for the rook this
would have surely been the end of link i
mean look at this this isn't some random
landslide this single boulder is going
straight for them what are the odds that
death mountain starts shaking in this
exact location and raining down a rock
this size to the exact place where link
is standing this isn't some
huge earthquake where tons of rock are
sliding down the mountain and they just
so happen to be in the path of
destruction
one very specific pillar breaks and only
sends down a small handful of rocks
soaring down
this is just too much of a coincidence
if you ask me
even the rook comments on the
strangeness of the situation
and how death mountain has been quiet
for decades the way this is shown and
word it definitely hints that this event
has something to do with calamity
ganon's return
and the game doesn't really make a big
secret out of this but i would go a step
further and say that this wasn't just
death mountain growing more restless
because calamity ganon is returning
i would suggest that this was a direct
attempt on link's life by ganondorf to
get rid of the hero before he has a
chance to mess with his plans
and if what i proposed in my breath the
wild chronological puzzle video is true
and ganondorf has the power to create
earthquakes like he did in the past
this random event on death mountain
being a strategically planned
assassination attempt becomes more
plausible last but not least
the timing of ganon's return this one
has been covered by other creators and
theorists and while this one does have a
high probability that this was just
coincidence or unfortunate timing it is
quite peculiar how everything played out
the moment calamity ganon finally
appeared
firstly it's on the exact day that zelda
ventures to the spring of wisdom with
the five champions
basically giving him a head start as all
the pilots are now nowhere near their
divine beasts
secondly the interruption of mifa right
as she is about to tell zelda that she
thinks of the one she loves
aka link when she uses her healing power
and thus possibly revealing how zelda
could unlock her power
she is unable to finish her sentence and
mipha had she been able to say what she
wanted to say
was totally right zelda's love for link
was ultimately what caused her to
finally awaken her sacred gift but by
the time she did
most of the damage had already been done
again this could be just
unfortunate timing but you gotta admit
this was very favorable for gannon and
could just as well have been
him pulling the strings yet again all
this stuff combined the sudden rise in
monster attacks the attempts on link and
zelda's life the confusing and
suspicious prophecy
the queen's death as well as all the
other strange coincidences taking place
leads me to believe that ganondorf had a
much greater influence on the world
above ground than the game initially
reveals
the big question that remains though is
how did ganondorf
know all of this how was he able to
coordinate so well while being sealed
deep on the ground
as we learn in game and from masterworks
ganondorf uses eyes of malice to see
above ground
and even the developers made it clear
that this was purposely done to always
remind you that ganon
is everywhere and always watching so
ganondorf is basically the architect
from the matrix
however during the events of 100 years
ago no malice was yet present above
ground until after ganondorf rose from
the depths of hyrule castle how was he
able to know where zelda would be where
link would be
where to execute his monster attacks or
assassination attempts
the only way this was possible is if
someone was coordinating with ganondorf
reporting to him feeding him information
and generally being his eyes and ears
above ground
this leads me into one of my favorite
theories about breath of the wild
that the yiga may have been directly
speaking with ganondorf not calamity
ganon
but the man himself the puppet master
how exactly this is achieved is not
entirely clear one theory presented by
mass nintendo bandits suggests that the
yiga possibly dug their way down into
hyrule's underground from within their
own hideout
this hole which is found in the arena
where you fight the present-day yiga
leader master koga is very suspicious
and well
just so random why would this huge and
seemingly bottomless pit be located here
it's features definitely show that it's
something man-made
whether or not this hole was already
here or dug by the yiga themselves or
since it's also connected to a shika
shrine in the dlc maybe dug by the
ancient shika
is up for debate but it does seem like
such a weird inclusion to their hideout
this hole has to be of more importance
than we are allowed to see in game i
mean it's just too weird
another possibility is that ganondorf
has simply been able to speak with the
yiga leadership
telepathically or spiritually or
whatever you want to call it
and give them instructions on what to do
next and again this
is something he has been able to do in
the past where we can hear him speak
without him actually being in the room
the yiga are in a lot of ways a bunch of
goofballs
it's just very hard for me to imagine
that they themselves came up with the
plan to kill zelda out of nowhere their
motivations in general
are not always very clear we know that
they are at war with the gerudo and they
are loyal to ganon but ganon has at this
point not been seen for the past
10 000 years it's kinda hard to stay
loyal not to mention
motivated and pass on the information on
what to do during the next attack for
such an insanely long time
up until the prophecy the hylians and
even the current day shika had
completely forgotten about even the
existence of ganon for all intents and
purposes the yiga are but one of ganon's
pawns on the chessboard a tool he can
use to aid him while he was scheming for
his return
it's unlikely that the yiga knew all the
rules and the key elements about the
events of ten thousand years ago
to this very day the yiga might be
badass ninja assassins
from outer space no not from space but
the point is they are not competent
enough to know about all the details
about gannon what he even looks like
what his plans are
and what needs to be done unless
ganondorf has been talking to them
the yiga used to be shika so their
lifespan is about the same which is only
a bit longer than the average hylian if
not even the shika and the hylians were
able to remember the existence of ganon
how would the yiga know
anything most of the information they
got was from spying on the hylians and
the chica who also didn't know much
you get the point the sudden increase in
their activity in the months leading up
to the great calamity seems to at least
indicate that they had some
access to ganondorf's plans maybe on a
need to know basis
ganondorf's inability to dispose of
lincoln zelda during and before the
great calamity
ultimately led to the defeat of his
malice puppet 100 years later however
this isn't to say that this was the
extent of his plans
perhaps breath the while 2 will reveal
ganondorf's plan b
and for all we know lincoln zelda's
little cave adventure which leads them
to finding his corpse is
all part of the plan maybe it's
ganondorf who sets them on this path and
wants to be found so he can break free
from his seal whatever the case may be
i am very excited to see what happens
and i'm also hoping that the game will
shed some more light on the events
during the backstory of brethwald who
this mysterious fortune teller was
why the queen died so suddenly and
unexpectedly since this is a direct
sequel we could see some of these events
play out from the perspective of
ganondorf
and if he is properly voiced which i
really hope he will be
he could explain more about himself and
his motivations like he did in twilight
princess and the wind waker
and that is all for now let me know in
the comments what you think of this
whole situation
what will ganondorf's plans be in breath
of the wild too will we see his malice
play another major role or will nintendo
tone this down
and focus on something else something
new perhaps
as always a big thanks to my patreons of
which i have a couple of new ones
joining the maze so
please welcome austin barrett jasper
freyka
legend of levy charles zazz as well as
an honorable mention to
steven and parker who just upgraded his
pledge thank you all
very much you beautiful people you i
will see you all next week for some more
zelda goodness and also look forward to
my paper mario the origami king review
very soon i hope you all have a
wonderful weekend and
this is don signing off have a good one